la vie lancha laa laa laa laa laa cheap
old la la job in sol la carne de mundo
which means beef meat this is ground
ground would be marginata so we also
call this in machi not o la salsiccia in
practice a molar in pan Graffiato in
Agra
tato Volvo today becomes feminine
guava parmigiana
we're going to create it so we will use
in parmigiana graph to Giotto la Sukeena
or low to ki no ill pecorino
this is pecorino romano larva chipolina
literally it means like oniony herb this
tribes la noche mascota
it's not my spices would be space yet
let specia la ricotta
in tom no that's - not in scott allah
can't install not in scott allah in
peperoncino this is some romaine lettuce
last la toga or
lin salata Romana I'm gonna repeat it
lat
- gah lah toga or in sur La Table in
Xalapa insalata Romana
El Padrino because there are little
Tomatoes if they were bigger we would
say in Ramadan cherry tomatoes to run
our Pomodori Lotito
balsamic of balsamic vinegar a Cheeto
nachito
but Sumiko okay so what is this all you
can get back let you fall in good and we
already saw this bucket film hard so I'm
going to remind you
yeah we have beef this is ground beef so
we would say la carbonate much inaudible
much Hinata so when you have like a
dynamic now that you can use one single
word and say then we have literally
created bread you can write it all
together or right yes and when we floral
it becomes family then what is this this
has no label because I think okay we
have all the endings and there are more
active you can say loads of Kino floral
boutique um it's okay or family lots of
kina and plural
Dena zucchini
it means juice
yes